if we solve the AI safety problem as
we've talked about and then you Max tag
Mark who has been talking about this uh
for many years get to sit down with the
AGI with the early AGI system on a beach
with a drink
what kind of what would you ask her what
kind of question would you ask what
would you talk about
something so much smarter than you
a really Zinger of a question that's a
good one would you be afraid
to ask some questions no
see I'm not afraid of the truth I'm very
humble I know I'm just a meat pie with
all these flaws you know but yeah I
I have that we talked a lot about Homo
sentience I really already tried that
for a long time with myself just so that
is what's really valuable about being
alive for me is that I have these
meaningful experiences
it's not that I'm
have what I'm good at this or good at
that or whatever because there's so much
I suck at then
so you're not afraid for the system to
show you just how dumb you are no no in
fact my son reminds me of that
you could find out how dumb you are in
terms of physics how little how little
we humans understand I'm cool with that
I think I think um
so I I can't waffle my way out of this
question it's a fair one it was tough
I think given that I'm a really really
curious person that's
really the defining part of who I am I'm
so curious
uh I have some Physics questions
I loved I would love to understand I
have some questions about Consciousness
about the nature of reality or just
really really love to understand also
I can tell you one for example that I've
been obsessing about a lot recently
so I believe that
it's supposed to Noni is right I suppose
there are some information processing
systems that are conscious and some that
are not suppose you can even make
reasonably smart things like gpt4 that
are not conscious but you can also make
them conscious
here's the question that keeps you make
at night
is it the case that the unconscious
zombie systems that are really
intelligent are also really efficient so
they're really inefficient
so that when you try to make things more
efficient we still naturally be a
pressure to do they become conscious
I'm kind of hoping that that's correct
and I do you want me to give you a hand
away the argument for it you know like
in my lab again every time we look at
how it how these large language models
do something we see that they do them in
really dumb ways and you could make it
make it better uh if if you uh
we have loops in our computer language
for a reason
the code would get way way longer if you
weren't allowed to use them it's more
efficient to have the loops
and
in order to have self-reflection whether
it's conscious or not right even an
operating system knows things about
itself right
you need to have loops already and so I
think this is I'm waving my hands a lot
but I suspect that um
the most efficient way of implementing a
given level of intelligence
has Loops in it the self-reflection it
can
and will be conscious isn't that great
news yes if it's true it's wonderful
because then we don't have to fear the
ultimate zombie apocalypse and I think
if you look at our brains actually our
brains are part zombie
and part conscious
when I open my eyes
I immediately
take all these pixels and hit my ref on
my retina right and I'm like oh that's
Lex but I have no freaking clue of how I
did that computation it's actually quite
complicated right it was only relatively
recently we could even do it well with
machines right you get a bunch of
information processing happening in my
retina and then it goes to the lateral
nucleus mythalamus into the area V1 V2
V4 and the fusiform face area here that
Nancy can wish or an MIT invented and
blah blah blah
I'd have no freaking clue how that
worked right it feels to me subjectively
like my conscious module
just got a little email it's like
face facial processing fit
task complete it's Lex yeah I'm gonna
just go with that right so this fits
perfectly with tanoni's model because
this was all one way information
processing mainly
and uh it turned out for that particular
task that's all you needed and it
probably was kind of the most efficient
way to do it but there are a lot of
other things that we associate with
higher intelligence and planning and and
so on and so forth where you kind of
want to have loops and be able to
ruminate and self-reflect and introspect
and so on where
my hunch is that if you want to fake
that with a zombie system that just all
goes one way you have to like unroll
those loops and it just really really
long and it's much more inefficient
so I'm actually hopeful that AI if in
the future we have all these various
Sublime and interesting machines that do
cool things
and are aligned with that
they will be at least they will also
have Consciousness for the kind of these
things that we do
the great intelligence is also
correlated to Great Consciousness or a
deep kind of Consciousness yes
so that's a happy thought for me because
the zombie of a couple of apocalypse
really is my worst nightmare of all it
would be like adding insult to injury
not only did we get replaced but we
freaking replaced ourselves by zombies
like how dumb can we be that's such a
beautiful vision and that's actually a
provable one that's one that we humans
can Intuit and prove that those two
things are correlated as we start to
understand what it means to be
intelligent and what it means to be
conscious which these systems uh early
agi-like systems will help us understand
and I just want to say one more thing
this is super important most of my
colleagues when I started going on in my
Consciousness tell me that it's all
and I should stop talking about
it
I hear a little inner voice from my
father and for my mom saying keep
talking about it because I think they're
wrong and and and
the main
way to convince people like that
that they're wrong if they say that
Consciousness is just equal to
intelligence just ask them what's wrong
with torture or why are You Against
torture
if it's just about you know
these these particles are moving this
way rather than that way
and there is no such thing as subjective
experience what's wrong with torture I
mean do you have a good comeback to that
no it seems like suffering suffering
imposed onto other humans is somehow
deeply wrong in a way that intelligence
doesn't quite explain but if someone
tells me well you know
It's Just an Illusion Consciousness uh
whatever you know
I would like to invite them the next
time they're having surgery to do it
without anesthesia
what is anesthesia really doing if you
have it you can have it local anesthesia
when you're awake I have that when they
fixed my shoulder right it's super
entertaining uh
what was that that it did it just
removed my subjective experience of pain
it didn't change anything if it was
actually happening in my shoulder right
so if someone says that's all
and skip the anesthesia as my advice
this is incredibly Central
it could be fundamental to whatever this
thing we have going on here it is
fundamental because we're we what we
feel is so fundamental is suffering and
joy and pleasure and meaning and
that's all those are all subjective
experiences there huh
and let's not those are the elephants in
the room that's what makes life worth
living and that's what can make it
horrible if it's just a bunch of
suffering so let's not make a mistake of
saying that that's all
and let's not make the mistake of uh
not instilling the AI systems with that
same
thing that makes us
um special yeah
Max uh it's a huge honor that you will
sit down to me the first time
uh on the first episode of this podcast
it's a huge honest sit down with me
again and talk about this what I think
is uh the most important topic
the most important problem that we
humans have to face and hopefully solve
yeah well the honor is all mine and I'm
so grateful to Youth for making more
people aware of the fact that Humanity
has reached the most important fork in
the road ever in its history and that's
turn in the correct direction